[Musique]
le
chanteuse poète comédienne brigitte
fontaine c'est un peu tout cela à la
fois samedi 24 septembre c'est elle qui
ouvrira la saison artistique du théâtre
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
accompagné par la troupe des musiques à
ouïr elle revisitera son répertoire dans
une orchestration varié et original est
à la fois un orchestre plein de plats de
sonorité
riche de sonorités on va dire
dans une forme de multitudes au niveau
des sons puisqu'on joue tous de
plusieurs instruments donc on se
retrouve dans une belle surprise
découverte sonore est dans la même
découverte sonore on se retrouve au beau
milieu de la poésie de brigitte fontaine
qui est aussi à dellys
incontournable de la chanson française
les plus grands titres de brigitte
fontaine reprendront vie le temps d'une
soirée un voyage où se mêlent free jazz
musiques orientales et influences plus
contemporaine interprétés les choses ça
veut dire
que l'herbe est un petit peu à sa sauce
et puis surtout surtout laisser la place
aux au public de
de faire de faire son histoire est une
chanson de brigitte fontaine c'est un
c'est un univers entier c'est un moment
et c'est une envie une excitation
[Musique]
oh
2 comme à la radio à la symphonie
pastorale des années 70 à aujourd'hui
le spectacle au brigitte est une
invitation à la folie de la reine des
kékés
[Musique]